what you're about to watch is a special
private training session for people who
bought a copy of my book built to serve
enjoy
well welcome everybody doing some built
to serve insiders readers group the poll
question was from michael who said
owning your time and schedule so
my quick take on this and then we'll get
to you know questions from you guys
whatever i can help answer in this
little mini break for us today um i love
energy zones i think i think staying in
the same energy zone really really
really matters so today is thursday
uh all of my public-facing stuff was on
a thursday i had i start with movement
makers which always gets me
i'm an introvert right so i don't wake
up and like hey michael jordan just in
time we're doing your question right now
michael drive safe though drive safe um
we uh
you know i get so much love from movie
makers that that that gets me fired up
for the rest of the day and so all i
have to do on a thursday is do
my public-facing stuff
so all day long it's just interviews and
and
sessions like this and podcasts and
movie makers and then three podcasts and
then this and then like four more
podcasts and a live stream tonight but
i'm not worried about my youtube channel
i'm not worried about my team i'm not
worried about anything else besides just
spreading the message today and i think
it's great to stay in that energy zone
because the energy i got from mover
makers i'm still pouring into the next
group and the love i get from you guys
i'm pouring into my podcast right after
this and so i don't have to switch i
think switching between different tasks
ends up being really really it's
challenging for everybody maybe extra
challenging for me
um because i think to spend half an hour
on a podcast and then 20 minutes right
in the book and then 40 minutes doing
something else you end up just getting
nothing done you feel like if you ever
felt like
i worked all day but i got nothing done
it's probably because you're switching
between energy states too much
and so all i have to worry about today
is this one thing of spreading the
message um
yesterday was my project day
so this this this is a change that i
made in the past year or year and a half
that really made a huge impact was
adding project day in the middle so
tuesday wednesday thursday tuesday is my
youtube day it's crazy it's crazy it's
just i got to make videos for 12
different channels
plus two strategy plus it's just
all day long
if you're on my team don't try to reach
me on a tuesday it's not gonna happen
i'm just making videos
thursdays today is crazy crazy just all
day long interviews and podcasts and
skypes and just all day long
so in the middle wednesday is open day
wednesday is my project day wednesday i
wake up i'm like what i want to work on
today
um it doesn't turn into like let's play
league of legends all day like i like
working but i get to basically pick
whatever project i want to work on and i
like having the freedom
in the middle of the week between the
two crazy days it used to be like write
my book day right you know if i'm
writing the book i need a whole day it's
hard to write a book in 20 minutes a day
because it takes you 20 minutes just to
get back into what you were doing any
kind of creative work if you're doing
creative work you need like chunks of
time without the stress of i need to be
done by one o'clock so i can go off and
do this thing that kills your creativity
so wednesday's creative work day
um
and and i've just found i get way way
way way way more stuff done working the
same number of hours but just way more
productive because i'm not shifting my
energy too much
now you may not be in complete control
of your day you might have a job you
might have customers you might have
other responsibilities family whatever
so whatever is inside your
calendar that you can control just being
more intentional with it
and making sure that what's in your
calendar is going to help you get your
goals right like if you want to have a
youtube channel i was talking about just
before this was on a podcast with the
guys like help me build my youtube
channel okay great
well show me where in your calendar have
you dedicated time to make youtube
videos
oh i haven't done that well that's why
you're not making youtube videos dude
[Laughter]
it's not on your calendar like if you
just hope you have time to do something
guess what hope is on a day of the week
you know it doesn't ever happen it's
like yeah that's why i haven't made a
video in the past three months okay
great so it's it's we can change that we
can add that we can put it in
um but your actions have to be you know
mapped to your ambitions what's in your
calendar has to be the thing that you're
working towards every day so
i like different days for different
things i have my morning routine which i
do
every day and then i fall into whatever
that day is going to be so mentoring day
monday youtube day tuesday
uh
open project day creative day thursdays
public facing day interviews friday is
ceo day grow the business saturday is
fun day
and then sunday's family at midday and
even that's an important distinction
sunday
is
go grocery shopping
do the laundry
uh
whatever i mean whatever has to get done
clean up the condo
you know all the all the stuff that you
have to do to live life that is not fun
but that's kind of required
we want to on a sunday but it's not on
saturday
i'm not folding laundry on a saturday
saturday is the only day where we don't
even do i don't even do the dishes you
know my wife cooks i do the dishes after
not saturday saturday
i'll leave the dishes for sunday
like saturday is fun day
and it's important i think to put up the
the blocks
on your calendar
to
more not just like what you are going to
do but what you're not going to do
i'm not going to
get interrupted by my team today i am
not going to work on my youtube channel
today i am not going to and i think that
that really helps you stay a lot more
focused
and then my last quick thought and then
we can open up if you want me to go in
deeper and michael know you're here so
if you've got questions on that which is
kind of top level but
it also lets you miss the work i like to
miss the work
like you guys we see each other once a
week now it's like i miss you guys in
between
you know it's like we get this and then
tomorrow i'm not missing you but then
come like tuesday when it's like ah
when we get the reader's group and then
thursday comes hey we're back
so
if you only do something once a week
you're always missing it
when it comes up
so i haven't made youtube videos since
tuesday i'm not missing it yet but come
like friday saturdays like i want to
make i want to make some youtube videos
so whatever day i'm about to jump into
i'm always missing the work
as opposed to kind of getting bored or
overwhelmed or whatever from it
um
so that's really helped me and again you
may not be able to control your whole
day
but whatever you can control
just being intentional with it and
asking yourself
hey over the next week i've got seven
days and inside inside of that i've got
14 hours that i can play with how am i
going to use those 14 hours
that are my time to be able to
move closer to achieving the goals that
i've got for myself
that's my quick my quick take
michael to help or you guys got extra
questions you want to dive deeper on it
i got another question
can i ask yeah michael then we're going
to we'll go to niall i saw his hand up
too what do you got okay uh so at the
end of the day do you have a time that
you stop with your work and then that's
your family time time to spend with your
kid uh or
with the wife or are you
like if you go to bed uh
like you're on
making videos until 8 pm and then you do
your bedtime routine and go to bed
so
if i look at a normal breakdown
um with kind of family time so we'll
i'll go for a walk with my wife in the
morning
so i'll take the dogs out they'll go for
a walk and we spend the first 45 minutes
to an hour of the day kind of just
setting up for the day we're both not
morning people so at the beginning we're
not really talking
it's kind of like holding hands and
walking outside
uh and then as like the sun hits you and
the fresh air we start
having a conversation hey how's it
what's up for today how'd you sleep last
night and just kind of i like welcoming
the day with some fresh air and not just
being inside all the time um
especially now with everything going on
it's like we don't get enough
outside stuff that we get to do
then usually we'll take a break at 2 30.
uh we both have that inner calories a
break for half an hour 2 30 to connect
it could be um
depending on how we're feeling it could
be another like quick outside just take
the dogs to the park super quick come
back up but that kind of built into our
schedule
um
after that i'll go back to work uh
usually
until at least five five to six is like
my buffer zone for anything urgent
so
you know today is my interview day i
actually have a gap from five to six but
i put that in because we booked so far
in advance for guests for my me to be on
shows that if something really urgent
comes up i hate having to
post postpone somebody or canceling
somebody like worst case we can but if
some big opportunity comes up we have
that as our buffer zone just kind of
like hotels often the the penthouse
suite is open just in case some big
person comes in
there's a room for them they have to
kick somebody out
um
six to 7 30ish i'm doing my live stream
usually four days a week with zan here
and and drew
and then from 7 30 to what
nine
uh it was usually playing with the kids
uh
right now we're doing
a lot of minecraft together
because three different cities you know
nieces and nephews all that stuff we
just join on a minecraft server together
i'm not very good at minecraft um but
whatever it's a fun thing to do and i
think there's a lot of actual life
lessons that happen like if you go and
you build your character in minecraft
and then you step into lava and you lose
all your stuff do you rage quit and
freak out or can you talk that through
right and like i think you can
parent and teach in life lessons through
everything and the more you're doing
things that they like as opposed to like
forcing to do what you want um
there's actually better teaching there
nine to ten nina and i usually watch a
show
right now we're watching homeland uh
we're on the last season of homeland
working our way through usually we're
watching like some of the superhero
movies or shows uh
legends of tomorrow and
what else we watch green arrow
uh anyway there was this big gap of no
shows coming out it's like oh we got
nothing to watch so we fell into
homeland and that's pretty good
but that's one hour
then i wash the dishes
take the dogs out
um answer the questions i do like ten
questions with evan
and then we get ready for bed
um
so that's a typical like monday to
friday kind of day friday night we'll
probably just stay up a little bit later
and do stuff together
but that's a typical weekday so
uh there's a morning time there's an
afternoon time and there's an evening
time
um spread out between like just the two
of us or time with family too so far
works but it's constant like minor
adjustments as we go nia what you got
hey can you hear me today yeah we got
you yeah excellent yes hey your wall is
basically the same as mine dude it's
just it's it's orange i don't i mine's
orange now yours is coming through with
red i love yours yours kind of looks red
just a little lighter but i like it dude
this is great yeah thanks and listen i
have been i haven't had a chance to
speak this is fantastic what you're
doing here and um i think this is great
and
everything that people share is
fantastic do you mind if i take it off
topic just for a little bit from the
scheduling or do you want to know
whatever whatever you guys want one
quick question i had was what would you
suggest or what's your thought on
building a brand on you as a person
compared to building a brand around an
entity or a company name or a theme
person's always easier
okay
your story is your greatest advantage
right why is somebody gonna buy from you
versus some giant corporation because
they feel like you actually care about
them
but where you lose is you don't have the
history you don't have the reputation
you don't have the name brand yet you
think about whoever the biggest
competitors are in your industry like
why it's the old expression if nobody
got fired for buying ibm
um like the big brands that they're
trusted so they may not treat you super
well but
at least you know what you're getting
and they have a history and they're
likely not going to screw you over
so if you're if you're a logo
you're basically taking the worst of
both worlds
where if you make it your personal brand
they may not
they may not know you yet but it's like
man this guy cares
that's why sharing your story right i
mean
why emphasize so much in here is sharing
your story matters is what makes people
connect to you that okay maybe you don't
have the history of the reputation yet
but man i feel like this guy actually
cares about me and i wanna i wanna
i wanna do business with him and how
about it sorry
how about if the theme itself uh
builds on and stems from my story and
how i could further serve that's that's
where i'm thinking i'm going considering
i've just recounted
myself but it wasn't it's not me
necessarily it's me i'm all that on my
branding but it's backed by a mantra
and that that has to tie to your purpose
of course yeah that's why you tell your
story because that's who you're trying
to help
in reading your story i need to feel
like oh my god this guy gets me right
this guy is exactly
who i am and i need i need his help but
you're you're a hundred steps ahead but
you're the same person and so i can
learn from you because
you get me
that's your biggest advantage your your
story is your biggest advantage as an
entrepreneur
right right i just didn't know if it
would be possession from hey nile
it's me or the concept of my brand
not the concept but the positioning of
my brand so it it opens up something
that's becomes familiar um very similar
to your your one word that's that's
where yeah like you are your brand right
right so it's not this isn't this is
what happened with
your one word and then built the service
believe isn't just
a strategy for me
i am believe it's my who
same thing for all you guys like when
you figure out your who it's who you are
and you show up
everywhere as that
so i i right now i'm believing in you
guys and i'm believing all the people
that i'm doing shows with afterwards but
when i when i come home and still
believe it's still spreading belief to
my wife and my family it's it's it takes
on a different life right i'm not
telling nina go make your youtube
content and spread your message but it's
still
you know believing in her so it's not
just a hat that you wear it's actually
who you are
so nile equals blank not just oh this is
my business stands for this but i stand
for something different
right perfect thank you vincent
varendra barindra
thank you thank you for having these
sessions uh wonderful to have you thanks
a lot first of all and uh hi everyone my
question is on this point you just
mentioned about the one word so i
got your one word book now so reading
through it but if you can kind of help
in terms of how we find it and we'll be
uh you know get that through quickly so
we can start more
did you go through the five questions
of like your favorite teacher i i i have
just started reading it yesterday only
so i have got to that point of chapter
two where the five questions are there
so i'll be going to answer them
okay so that that honestly that's the
best thing like go through the questions
the both books were not designed as just
uh
read the book and put it away it's like
it's it's a
you have to think you have to do the
exercises you know it's a it's almost a
workbook inside a book
um if you want to get the value out of
it i think the best thing is go through
the questions and if you get stuck
come back next week and and we'll
workshop it
okay yeah fine bye thank you
i saw a lady had her hand up lady lexie
i'm trying to figure out how to work my
schedule uh as in
recording videos and all the other stuff
ever since i've been dealing with the
death of my mom and my cat and i'm
swamped by
whether it's an appointment with the
attorney cleaning up the house
you name it real estate agents of course
my brother my sister
but you know i have limited amount of
energy i have to juggle through it all
so you were talking about your schedule
during the day and i'm like okay
how would i be able to maintain some
sort of schedule
uh along with the regular clients i've
got and and trying to get my story
online that's actually why i didn't
record because i was so tired at night
yeah so
you know there are moments where you
need to give yourself more grace
right and and you know
sorry to hear about your mom and your
cat and
um you know we lost our family dog
uh not too long ago and
some people you know see that as mushy
or whatever but that's a big deal like
it's part of your family
um we also lost uh my sister-in-law
last year
at the end of the year um
like 40 years old died to some super
rare cancer three kids
um one teen and two preteens and that uh
that took us all out
you know i was not being nearly as
productive
as i could have been um
uh i wasn't doing as many shows as i
usually had uh my wednesday or friday
might have been completely
gone instead of doing creative work i'm
spending the time with my nieces or
nephews just
not even doing much just being with them
because their mom just died and what do
you do as an eight-year-old right just
to have some kind of
love
there um they're still you know they
were trying to figure out school or no
school and just dealing with it
um so there's grace you know there are
some moments in life where you have to
give yourself a little bit more grace
and understand that you're not going to
be at your regular capacity when i broke
my neck
you know
that was brutal
but i still made videos every day
you know i think like having something
that you can hang your head on to
to even if you're
even if you're tired even if you're not
100 just to look back and say like i'm
still
not giving up on my
ambitions
so whatever that looks like for you
like if making videos is really
important to you
i would still make videos and posts like
you could make a five minute video i
made a video from my hospital bed
with my broken neck and a concussion
and
doug wadler is not here in the house
right now but he took a screenshot of it
and it looks like i'm dead
i mean it's probably just a bad
screenshot too but i've got my neck
brace on like this giant scab across my
forehead
and
it was definitely not anywhere close to
being my best content but i'm you know
looking back super proud that i still
did it
to do the difficult thing when it's hard
it wasn't my best content it was a five
minute video instead of i committed to
going live every day
right while i was on my tour and
everybody
yeah
so it's it's okay to to let go of the
structure you know with opinion and all
that stuff and just post like one minute
videos and
you know wish out the beginning and the
end you know the bumper and the footer
yeah
let go of all that
at the end of the day
all that matters is how proud are you of
yourself
are you proud that you did the best that
you could given what you had
so if you're gonna say hey i can either
not make a video because it's not
perfect or i can make a one-minute video
with everything else going on but it
won't have to structure
i'd rather you make the one minute video
okay
i did record them i just didn't post
them or
them and i didn't write notes so i would
like to go in it you know after all
post and then recognize now if it's
a year later and you're still
here that's a problem right so like
there's a grace period and grief is real
right but if it's
three years later and you're still in
grief and you still can't do anything
then that's that's a bigger problem that
we need to to work through but for the
most part i think of all the negative
emotions
you know if you think positive emotions
like courage and ambition and drive and
service and all that and negative
emotions of of fear and anger and
jealousy and
all of that
every negative emotion
i want to try to eliminate from my life
except for grief
grief is a special one
like i don't want to have jealousy in my
life i don't want to have
anger or
any of the like strong negative emotions
but grief not that i want grief in my
life but it's it it just has to be work
through
like if i'm jealous about somebody i
don't want to work through i want to fix
it and get rid of it i don't want to be
jealous of other people but grief you
can't just
get rid of it like if you dive into your
work
it's still there
you know you can't just forget about it
and so you have to work through it and
time will heal and you won't be as
productive as you could be normally
would be and that's fine there's a
little bit of
grace i think all of us we've and if you
haven't had any grief yet it's it's
gonna happen at some point i mean it's
just the human experience
oh i i did i did have it and of course i
still go to to therapy like two times a
week for my ankle so
you know it's juggling with the limited
amount of energy but i i also noticed
that i really want to continue on with
the business the drive is there
so release make your one-minute videos
and release it
okay thank you
i'm feeling workshop mode today who's
got something that uh i can help with
tanya's got her hand up what do we got
tanya yes hello evan hello everyone so
good to see your faces every week i'm
having this you know um
kind of like starting exercises about
how to share
my story like storytelling because most
of my life i've been you know i love
stories but i've been the listener not
really the ones that shares
so i'm kind of like
learning how to do it and um
[Music]
one thing that i find challenging is
because
when you share right and uh in and you
don't want to share specific parts of it
because any consideration personal
whatever consideration right
how do you feel like or how do you
manage that feeling of being less
authentic if you don't share them
you know
those those parts that you don't want to
share and not because you don't want to
share them because of you sometimes you
do it because it's not only your story
it belongs to someone else too and that
someone else deserves the right to tell
the story in their own terms and they
are not going to have that audience
uh you don't wanna you know you don't
want to own
you don't wanna put that person on the
spot yeah if there was not you know
yeah
well first let's let's acknowledge you
because you you're sharing your story
right here
yeah like you're doing it
and i remember when you first joined uh
this group
the first couple times you didn't say
anything
never raise your hand you know zayn
zen had to pick on you and say okay
tanya
you gotta share something
[Laughter]
and he pulled you in and then here
i said hey guys let's just do a q a you
know and for anybody new here welcome
i'd like to have this group for people
who've you know got the book and have it
be resource and um you know do some
support in ongoing communities so you're
not alone on your journey and as soon as
i said hey we're going to do q a tanya's
hand is like the first one up
right what what a change over the past i
don't know the couple months it hasn't
been that long
um so
you're already doing it you're already
way ahead of what you were doing before
you're already sharing it is and it's
awesome
um
now inside of any story that you're
sharing
some of the things i'll always do not
always but often do is change change the
gender change the relationship if it's
somebody else
um because usually that doesn't matter
so in i mean the book that i just wrote
if i'm saying somebody's name
that you're you know you're one of the
readers for the beta readers for the
group um
i cleared it with them so there's a
really personal story about nina in
there obviously cleared it with her
before posted it i wrote it and then
uh i let her read it afterwards and i
think i wrote even in the book i don't
know if this is even going to make it
into the book
and and then i asked her the next day
and she's like yeah i just include it
it's like you might want to read it
first
and then she write it and she started
crying and she said no it's okay put put
it in
i talk about mark and i talk about
my agent steve in the book and i use
their names and i i
i wrote to them and asked them hey
here's what i wrote are you okay with it
being in the book and they both said yes
there's other people that i talk about
where
details minor details might change
gender might change a city therein might
change because that stuff doesn't really
matter
um
and then for other people that you just
might have to
not talk about it you know there's lots
that i don't share about my parents
because they're very private people
so you know a couple stories um but most
of the stuff with them i don't share
and and i love my parents like they're
on my wall you know in front of me here
but because they're private and they
don't want you know content living on
the internet about them then i don't i
don't talk about it um
it's just knowing that you have enough
other stories
you know there's enough other things
that are happening that don't involve
other people or you can share your
perspective that still provide
tremendous value to people
and and
even again back to what you just did
today
you raised your hand and what did you
share you shared that you were having
uh doubts or anxiety around
how do i share stories
yeah like you're doing it it's your
perspective without throwing somebody
else under the bus
i'm not in the throw people under the
bus
category um
some people might be he's like no like
that guy is a loser and i'm gonna let
the world know that he's a loser he's
like okay cool like if that's your style
go for it but um
there's a lot you can share without
having to tell somebody else's side and
and i hear you it's their story to share
there's so many other stories that you
could tell that still gives a lot of
value to people
does that make sense
uh yes like i need to yeah i was doing
this kind of like
self-exercise about okay why do i feel
so uncomfortable or how can i manage
this should i
you know let leave this uh storytelling
at the side at all maybe i'm you know
not uh not that good at it i don't know
many thoughts and uh what i end up
concluding and you know what you're
doing
makes sense because probably i need to
to to to choose why what i want to share
and
why like not need to share everything to
feel authentic
that's that's kind of the thing right if
i don't share
some things would i feel less authentic
and uh well i need to find out what are
those things that
are
are good to share are fine to share they
may be difficult but
at the same time won't affect anybody
else because that's the last thing that
i want to do right so it's kind of like
that exercise of going over and over and
see how can i share my story what do i
want to share and why why do i want to
share i just want to start talking about
something just because i want more
people to follow me
no i don't want that i have a purpose so
i just need to find
what i want to share why and
i guess that little by little i find out
how you know
doing these exercises and trying to get
better i'll find how to share in like a
more effective way
so yeah what you're saying yeah makes
sense you choose what you want to share
like yeah definitely and that doesn't
make me less authentic right
yeah so like if you were going to share
a story of
of one of your students
that you helped
is there a student that like comes to
mind that has a story that there's a
lesson inside of
oh yes yeah definitely i can you know
yeah i have uh i have a lot of stories
of students and it's easier it's more
difficult when it's something personal
when it's something very close
you know like very you know when you
have to tap into your pain kind of thing
that's more that's when it comes more
difficult
but i mean it it should be more
difficult
yeah you know and and but like even even
with a student it might be painful like
maybe you let them down or maybe they
disappointed you or maybe you made a
mistake or
it could be you know a million different
things that potentially went wrong
not just talking about the inspiring
stories but also some of the ones that
where you felt pain and then how did you
get through it are you still working
through it
yes yeah yeah definitely yesterday i had
one like
just yesterday yeah there's always you
know stories happening around everyone's
life right and yesterday i had a refusal
uh for one of my students
and uh you know i when whenever that
happens i you know i need to address and
talk and explain what happened and uh
husband was okay wife not so much and uh
you know it was at the end of the
afternoon i took this appointment at the
end of the afternoon and because i
wanted to talk to them i wanted to
address as soon as possible but uh you
know she said something like you know
she should be more enthusiastic about
reapplying she was harsh like you know
it is when i have a situation like this
it's hard for me as well because it's i
put a lot of work on it and it when it
doesn't work sometimes most of the times
work
sometimes it doesn't
so it's hard on me too so i heard i
heard say
she's saying that until it hurt it hurts
right but she was like well she at least
she should put more excitement on trying
to reapply
and uh i understand her situation i
understand her position but at the same
time it's painful for the person because
we're we're not uh kind of like
infallible machines we are and it's not
my mistake it was not my mistake
sometimes it happens it's their
situation which is not ideal and you
know sometimes that happens
but i'm dealing with the with the
frustration it's hard
it's hard and uh and uh you know let's
see what happens with them like
hopefully i can turn okay so how did you
deal with the situation how did it make
you feel and how did you deal with it
at that point it was almost 6 p.m i was
with my energy very low
and
i recognized that she felt uh she felt
probably dismissed like i was not really
feeling what they were feeling
so i told the house and i told look i
understand
how frustrating is this because it's not
just a no to a paper it's a no to a
dream you have
and but we we set clear expectations
from the beginning so you knew that this
could happen
so it's not that i'm not enthusiastic if
you want to proceed and reapply we will
and you know we will do the best we can
and uh you know it's not that i don't
feel your pain
so i that wasn't as much as i could do
my energy it was not
you know like probably i could do
something better but
that's what i managed to do at that time
and with you know that
mindset so think about that story
what would the lesson in the story be
there's a lot of different ways you
could take it
what's the lesson for people in that
story
the lesson is that
sometimes
you
have to deal
with
a negative outcome
regardless how much effort you put
sometimes happens
especially if it's not under your
control
but
probably what i would say is important
is to be upfront from the beginning
so there is no like
major damage beyond what you know of
course the disappointment and the time
and those things
it's uh it's it's hard when these
situations happen
for people it's very frustrating and
they react different ways that's the
lesson that's something everybody here
can connect
to the details of the story
don't matter
like the the person's name doesn't
matter the person gender doesn't matter
what they're hiring you for
doesn't matter all that matters is you
were trying to do something for a client
and you didn't get the result that they
wanted
and
they
made you feel really bad with a with a
with a comment out of frustration and
how it made you feel and then what you
did afterwards
you could tell that story
like you can tell that story in two ways
you can tell the story like you told us
and you can include the name you can say
hey
you know jose you know was my client who
hired me to do this and it got rejected
and and then his wife said this person
tiny doesn't care like you can go into
all the details
but those don't really matter as much as
the summary is you've got a client
who
is not happy with you and said something
mean about you
uh out of their frustration
at the end of a really long day
like how do you show up
so what really matters inside that story
is how did it make you feel
and then what did you do afterwards
so when they say hey tanya
it doesn't even look like she's trying
the most important part of the story is
how did that actually when when she said
those words how did that make you feel
i'd have you've been putting the effort
and the work and you're trying and you
do this and we set expectations and
then they said this and it just
like that's the most important part did
it crush you did you cry did you need to
go meditate like what those you know
words like but if there's no emotion to
it then then it's not really a story
worth sharing if you can just brush it
off and get back up then it doesn't
really matter but if when something hits
you like say that did destroy you say
those words like
just crushed you
then that's a story that you can share
without
naming the client or if they watch the
video they may not even know it's them
like it doesn't have to reference them
you could change the gender
it doesn't matter what they're hiring
you for all that matters is how the
situation made you feel and what you did
afterwards that's the lesson so in
telling a story if i'm going to tell a
story
about zen there's lots of stories i
could tell about zayn you know it's like
well what's what's the what's the
outcome that i like what's the lesson i
want people to have
and then i can tell the right story
around it and i don't even have to have
it as zane
like if there was something that was
gonna be
you know if if uh
you know zayn zan and i met up in vegas
last week or last month and uh
uh
he he was supposed to wear a mask the
whole time this is a good film this is a
fun one uh his wife insisted that he
wear a mask the whole time and he didn't
wear a mask
you know for almost any of it
and so it could be it could be about
environment like why well because he's
in a room where nobody's wearing a mask
and it feels awkward and uncomfortable
to be the only one wearing the mask and
and so he told his wife that he was not
wearing the math and so
i could make that about environment like
the environment you're in really matters
if you're around people who are doing
the things that you want then
you're more likely to be pulled up but
if you're around people who are living
the way that you don't want
or is against what you said you would do
it's a lot harder to stay consistent
and
i wouldn't tell that story about zayn
publicly on my youtube channel
you know i i would i the fact that he's
here and you can hear me say it and it's
in like a fun group we can i'll do that
but uh i wouldn't share that story as an
example on my youtube channel without
him hearing it
um
but i could still share that story about
i could i could change it up he's like i
was at this event and i was i met an
entrepreneur who said that she wanted to
wear masks the whole time
and
and she promised people in her life that
she would and then as soon as she came
out she didn't like she was walking
around without the mask on like wait
what happened like well nobody else is
wearing a mask like you just changed it
up without identifying zayn change the
gender say the entrepreneur like it
doesn't matter that it's zan
right um there's very few circumstances
where it actually does like if it's your
mom or your parents or something then
maybe there's something really deeply
personal like it'd only be them
it could only be them
um
you know there's abuse or something like
it can only be them um
but most stories you can easily flip
around because the point is your how you
felt in your journey through it not so
much about the specifics of the person
anyway i hope that helps tanya and we
went we went along on it but i think
it's valuable for others who are kind of
struggling with with the same thing and
definitely i struggled with too and what
i'm saying is not
it's simple but it's not easy
especially when you're diving into like
the the emotion of how it made you feel
the most important thing if i was going
to tell the zan story about
um environment
i'd have to connect it like i would make
it even stronger is for me how did it
make me feel
am i am i
upset that he's um
not doing it am i
am i upset that am i disappointed in
myself for not being a better
role model should i have worn a mask
like whatever no i don't actually care
enough about it it's just more of a
funny story but if it like how does it
impact me
is what makes for much better story
so how does it impact you that creates
like that emotion that you have is the
thing that's worth diving into more than
the specifics of what happened in the
story maria's got her hand up what do we
got maria
thank you evan actually i have something
that sort of piggybacks off of tanya's
question so great and maybe i missed it
but i've been listening but anyway when
i when i share like an example i say i
work i recently worked with a client
and i give an example and i because my
niche is women i don't really change the
sex
um
but i i wouldn't say their name of
course
unless of course they you know like said
oh share this story publicly but i still
feel like
i just feel sometimes i'm after i do it
like it feels like it flows and it's the
perfect thing because it is an example
of what needs to be said at that moment
like it's not like premeditated even it
just sort of comes up you know like oh
that's interesting i just worked with
the client and
but then afterwards i sort of feel
there's two things i feel a little
uncomfortable because i don't because
i'm afraid they're going to recognize
themselves and the other thing is i'm
thinking when other people hear that are
they going to be worried that i'm going
to like if they work with me are they
going to be worried that i'm going to
share oh i just work with a client
and we had this problem
so i don't know if i'm like overthinking
it or what are your thoughts on that
still like how do you you know share an
example you work with a client who what
who um
i mean perfect example would be
um
yesterday i was working with a client
and
she was
struggling
so she's struggling with a lot of guilt
and when someone her partner says to
harold your beliefs create your reality
it makes her even feel guiltier because
it's like look at the mess that i've
created you know and and so it spirals
it spirals her down he's intending to
uplift her right
and but really it's creating even more
of the problem for her
that's a little bit of an example of
what i might say if we were talking
about that how the insidiousness of
guilt can creep in in
just what's showing up in your life
and and then what's the what's the
lesson what's the message out of that
the message out of
out of that um particular thing is we we
worked on the guilt that was showing up
around that because it had not so much
to do with the circumstance it was the
guilt that was just sort of rearing its
head in all different areas
right so that means so that's the story
but what's the message like you need to
eliminate guilt from your life or what
what's what's the what's the takeaway
like the whole point of telling a story
is to have some kind of way that i can
go so yeah i hear that story yeah i mean
i'm just sort of
not even like thinking through this
whole thing no no no i'll get it i get
it we're workshopping it that's what
we're doing here together so so the
message would be that it comes down to a
belief that she has about herself that
she's not enough
and that you know
let's start addressing the guilt that's
showing up it's not that he needs to
change what he's saying to her so much
it's an opportunity for her to realize
that this circumstance is triggering the
guilt but the guilt is in her
it's not the circumstances right so
that's what we and that's
based on a false premise that she's
there's something wrong with her or
she's not enough or she has to do it
perfectly or because that's like the
core issue that we've been working on
okay so there's a couple
this is interesting now so what what
would be the single biggest takeaway
from
this story what do you want people to
walk away with
oh so um
there's nothing wrong with you it's not
about the circumstances
if you're plagued with guilt
it's not
it's
there's a false premise there's a false
belief there's an erroneous belief that
you've you picked up in life it's not
who you truly are you're valuable you're
worthy you're enough
but all that stuff is getting in the way
of you seeing yourself that way
and so the opportunity is when stuff
like this comes up into your life
it's a it's sort of mirroring back to
you how you feel not so much because
you're a bad person is it's it's like
goes back to the belief creates a
reality is that that reality is showing
up because it's showing you that you
have this belief that you're not enough
and that's what we can change right
because it's
the guilt is sort of like the outer
piece of you know that's an indicator
and we talked we had a whole
conversation around guilt and shame
because the real issue far was
perfectionism and perfectionism is
really usually a cover for not you know
guilt and shame so it sort of goes deep
but that but the takeaway is that these
erroneous beliefs that we
we
pick up along the way are not really who
who we truly are and they get in the way
of us
reaching our you know
living our successful life
so this is this is um this is great
thank you for kind of being our guinea
pig and being on the spot it's it's fun
to workshop these things because i go
through this too and trying to figure
out storytelling
um
you have two options
either you
start with a message and then you look
for a story or you start with a story
and look for the message but you need
both right like a a a message of a story
is not as powerful in a story without a
message like what am i here what am i
learning so if i was gonna talk about
environment matters maybe i then go and
find a story like zan in vegas or if i
start with zen in vegas there's a
thousand stories there's a thousand
stories i can pick to kind of get the
message right so i gotta go
you can both work so if you're coming
out of a session with a client
out of this one
why i was trying to kind of figure out
the path is because from this one
conversation with this woman you could
tell eight different stories and have
eight different messages
in what you're sharing about erroneous
beliefs that you pick up along the way
is not who you truly are like if that's
what we're trying to get around then
what the husband said to her doesn't
even matter
right well it mattered to her in the
moment but but you're right but it
doesn't it doesn't of course it yes of
course and you covered a lot in your
call but to to yours to your message of
what you're trying to get out
you don't have to say the husband's
story at all
if it's just about the fact that she has
been plagued by guilt
you don't have to talk about the husband
in that situation
if you're going to talk about how the
people around us you mentioned
environment a little bit and like the
people around us talking to okay then
that the relationship matters and the
husband could be a friend or the husband
could be someone in their life
right
but
your message is more about her own
internal beliefs
and believe that she's not enough
and so where does that come from and how
is that manifested in her life and some
of the things that she's trying to do
you could tell that whole story without
talking about the husband at all if the
message was
the belief that you're not good enough
okay
so what we did was we took a okay and i
i threw you up
you know right this was not planned to
prepare it so like thank you for
participating in you know and playing
catch with me but i think it's something
that we go through as trying to create
the stories to share in our videos is
you okay give me an example so in the
example
really there's like three or four or
five different potential messages from
that one example and if you i'm sure you
can go with another 10 if you needed to
based off of just thinking back to the
actual experience with her
and so it's it's only telling the things
that are relevant if one makes for a
much better video
right it's like like why are we bringing
a husband into this that doesn't even
make sense it doesn't fit the storyline
that one's that one example
um
[Music]
and so asking yourself like what's the
message from this story
can help align
clarity same thing with tanya like
what's the message from this well the
message is
uh if the message for her was that
you know bad things happen and you have
to bounce back from it then
all the details over who the client was
and what they it doesn't doesn't matter
so it allows us to tell a story and cut
out the details that
might identify somebody or make them
feel upset
and we're keeping in the things that
only matter to that specific story
okay does that make sense
yeah
yeah you could tell a great story about
her talking about guilt
that never identifies her that doesn't
bring in the husband and just how guilt
is holding is holding her back and then
what you did to release the guilt so
what we had to do was we did
x one i sat and listened to her and two
i told her to
like whatever the advice was to help
get her out of nothing actually
what's that he did emotional tapping
cool so like here's what we did so we
started tapping and like and and now
you're just talking about a woman who
has guilt
you know it's like
everybody has guilt
everybody believe has erroneous beliefs
that we've picked up along the way now
it's something that's really
relevant to the people you're trying to
serve well the key though that the real
the breakthrough came in the in the
session
was as we uncovered all of that
and we did some tapping around because
the emotion you know the guilt was
that at one point i just spontaneously
said to her you didn't create like the
creating piece was like getting in the
way of create the reality i think
like her whole lifetime she was feeling
like
she created
the prop the fact that she doesn't feel
good enough like she keeps beating
herself up and i said just
like spontaneously said i said you
didn't create that
and that like hit her and she's like
that's like
ready to turn my life around because
i've been blaming myself that i've
created
you know all that stuff and i was like
you're this innocent child in a theta
state that just picked up those beliefs
you didn't create them in the first
place you know
yeah so i mean that so now we have
that's a message right you didn't create
those beliefs so if you're gonna follow
the structure now from built to serve
you've got your powerful beliefs your
powerful opinion at the beginning
you did not create those negative
beliefs in your head
powerful opinion right like
contact sentence
the the voice in your head that's
telling you that you can't do it and
you're not good enough
is not your voice those are planted in
you by other people
contact sentences racist takes
if you do not fix this voice in your
head you will continue to believe the
lies that are keeping you small good
right
powerful opinion so powerfully content
sentences raise the stakes cool story
so the other day i was talking to one of
my clients and she's this beautiful
woman who's dealing with a lot of guilt
and
i was on a call with her and and she's
sharing her story about how
she doesn't feel good enough and how she
doesn't feel she's capable and she's got
all these amazing dreams inside her for
what she could create but just never
takes the steps to make it happen and so
as we started doing a tapping exercise
that i love to do with my clients
it flowed through me that
i said you did not create those beliefs
and that was her biggest aha takeaway
moment
that she stopped
and she said
you're right or like like whatever like
we can adjust some of the rent but she
said you're right and that became the
big breakthrough moment for her because
she had lived her entire life feeling
like she
wasn't good enough and that that voice
was hers and she was blaming herself and
she was blaming herself for doing it
right
yeah
and so
i'm here to tell you that those now we
move on that's the story i'm here to
tell you that
those beliefs are not yours they were
planted in you
and so now we have to do the work to
identify who planted it and how to get
it out here's what we're gonna do step
one we're gonna start tapping
right and so like you tell the story but
it could be almost anybody like who who
hasn't i'm that woman
[Laughter]
yeah
right
so that allows you to tell the story and
then and then you move into giving
advice and tapping or whatever else you
you want to do but um
it's not personally identifiable at all
we're not talking about her husband in
that situation and it could be
right you could easily say and on
june 2nd i met with sally tom thompson
and she told me this about her husband
you know like then it's obviously we
wouldn't do that but there's a way to
tell the story like that that um
i mean i just made that up based off of
what you told me yeah it was great
you're so good at that
let's just practice i wasn't good at
that right it's just practice going
through the process
if you want to get a copy of build to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there i'll see you there
i'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love